kia ora i'm darren ludlow invercargill
city councillor and one of the members
of the southern museum and art galleries
trust board
the museum was closed after we had an
intrusive survey to check to see how
safe it was
against the earthquake prone building
standards and once the standards changed
again we realized that there were severe
issues in some parts of the building
once we realized that they were below
the minimum
standard the infracargo city council
made a decision to withdraw its staff as
a matter of safety
it's pretty unlikely that the building
won't be the same
although our hope is to maintain the
iconic pyramid status
we want something that's got a lot more
space for different and more interactive
exhibitions
and what that's going to require is for
a storage facility to be built
nearby once we can shift the collection
into that we've got a whole lot more
space under that pyramid to put stuff
that people won't have seen for a long
time
nothing's easy and nothing's cheap there
have been calls for extra studies to be
done
into what the uh the issues are
particularly with the building from
those who would just like to see it
reopened
it is tremendously unlikely that that's
going to be the case
but before we can build and
improve what's there we have to build
the storage facility
and before we can build the storage
facility we've got to catalogue the
collection
it's a huge collection staff are making
their way through that as quickly as
they can
but it's not going to be a quick fix it
might still be another couple of years
you